Hello, the Internet.
I'm Gav.
Welcome to this Slow Mo Guys video.
You'll have to pardon my appearance,
my barber is closed.
How inconsiderate of him.
This video is slightly different
because my co-star is Smee the cat.
He is a six-year-old Siamese,
and he may look slightly tired
because he spent the entire day
pelting it about the garden
like an absolute lunatic.
Why don't we take a look
at some lovely slow mo footage of that?
You did so well, boy.
You were absolutely leggin' it.
Bit clumsy, though, he does
land on his back an awful lot.
You're supposed to land
on your feet, Smee.
It's one of the few things
you're supposed to do.
I, honestly makes me wish that
I had this wicked high-speed camera set-up
when he was a kitten,
because he was a very cute,
and very clumsy kitten.
I could've filmed a
bunch of that in slow mo.
Oh wait,
I did.
This is Smee.
His favorite camera is the Phantom Flex.
As you can see, I'm filming him drinking
a little bit of water, aren't I, Smee?
Well, there you have it, Slow Mo Cat.
Unbeatable, internet.
In my opinion.
Big thanks to Smee, the cat,
who is suitably exhausted.
And big thanks to Turney,
who helped me run around
the garden like a lunatic.
Hopefully, you enjoyed that video.
Make sure you subscribe,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Who knows what that one will be about.